ANYBODY ARE COMING.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, MIRANDA
DEVINE AND MARK MEADOWS,
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH
US.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM FROM A
GREAT STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA,
SARAH, HOW ARE YOU, GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK.
YOU RECENTLY --
>> GOOD TO BE BACK.
>> Sean: YOU RECENTLY GOT BACK
FROM TAIWAN.
I'VE GOT TO IMAGINE THEY ARE IN
A HEIGHTENED STATE OF ALERT
BASED ON THE OBVIOUS, THE
FIGHTER JETS FROM CHINA FLYING
OVER THEIR AIRSPACE VERY
REGULARLY, THE TALK OF
REUNIFICATION BY PRESIDENT XI,
THAT IS NOT REUNIFICATION, IT
WOULD BE A TAKEOVER OF A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY, AND IN LIGHT
OF THE LACKLUSTER RESPONSE OF
BIDEN IN UKRAINE, I'M NOT
IMPRESSED, PARTICULARLY, I WOULD
SAY THE ODDS ARE PRETTY HIGH
THAT THIS IS COMING.
ARE WE PREPARED FOR THAT?
>> WELL, HOW UKRAINIANS REALLY
WILL DETERMINE WHAT HAPPENS IN
TAIWAN, I WENT TO AUSTRALIA,
TAIWAN, AND JAPAN.
AFGHANISTAN LOOMS LARGE.
EVERYBODY IS DOUBTING AMERICA'S
RESOLVE AFTER AFGHANISTAN.
BUT THE FIGHT THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE ARE GIVING TO THE
RUSSIANS HAS INSPIRED OF THE
TAIWANESE.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO CHANGE THEIR
CONSCRIPTION LAWS TO MAKE PEOPLE
SERVE LONGER, TO GO TO A CIVIL
DEFENSE FORCE.
AMERICA NEEDS TO UP ITS GAME IN
ASIA.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE CHINA A
GREAT GIFT, DESTROY OUR ECONOMY
BY REDUCING CARBON HERE IN
AMERICA BY 50% BY 2030 AND DO
NOTHING TO CHINA AND INDIA.
THE CHINESE AND THE INDIAN
ECONOMY WOULD FLOURISH IF WE
DESTROYED MANUFACTURING --
AND JAPAN'S EXPANDING THEIR
DEFENSE FOOTPRINT.
WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE THAT.
SO AFGHANISTAN LOOMS LARGE AND
BIDEN, THERE'S A LOT OF DOUBT
ABOUT AMERICA AND WE NEED TO
REMOVE THAT DOUBT IF WE CAN.
>> Sean: I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
OIL, GAS, COAL, BEING THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THE WARD'S ECONOMY.
NOW BY ABANDONING THE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE POLICIES, ONE OF
THE GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, MAYBE ONE
OF THE TOP, BECAUSE ENERGY WAS
SO CHEAP AND ABUNDANT.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
GEOPOLITICAL IMPLICATIONS OF
ABANDONING THOSE POLICIES ARE
FELT NOT ONLY IN UKRAINE BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE FELT IN CHINA,
AND WE ALMOST SEE A REALIGNMENT
OF ALLIANCES IN THE WORLD.
YOU SEE THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
PRESIDENT XI AND THE IRANIAN
MULLAHS SEEM TO BE GETTING
CLOSER.
THAT IS AN AXIS OF EVIL THAT THE
WORLD WILL HAVE TO RECKON WITH
ONE DAY IF THAT HAPPENS.
>> WELL, EVERYBODY IS HEDGING
THEIR BETS.
LOOK AT INDIA.
INDIA IS RELUCTANT TO TAKE RUSH
ON BECAUSE THEY BUY ALL THEIR
WEAPONS FROM RUSSIA.
WITHOUT AMERICAN LEADERSHIP,
WHERE THE GLUE THAT HOLDS THE
WORLD TOGETHER, PEOPLE IN JAPAN,
AUSTRALIA, AND TAIWAN ARE
YEARNING FOR RONALD REAGAN-TYPE
LEADERSHIP AND ONE THING I WOULD
SAY TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
EVERYTHING YOU SAY ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS IS TRUE IN TERMS OF
THEIR POLICY, BUT I'M BEGGING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO COME UP WITH
AN AMERICA FIRST AGENDA THAT
ADDRESSES THE BORDER, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, INFLATION, A
STRONG NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE OTHER SIDE.
WE NEED TO HAVE A VISION OF HOW
WE WOULD CHANGE THIS COUNTRY AND
RESTORE ORDER AND MAKE THE
ECONOMY STRONGER AT HOME.
WE NEED A POSITIVE AGENDA THAT
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO RUN THESE
GUYS DOWN EVERY NIGHT --
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WANT TO
ASK --
SPEAK WHAT WE WOULD DO.
>> Sean: NEWT GINGRICH HAS
SPOKEN TO ME IN KEVIN McCARTHY
IS COMING UP NEXT ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE --
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> Sean: AS OF NOW, THE TOP
TEN THINGS REPUBLICANS PLEDGE,
PROMISE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THEY WOULD DO.
SOMETHING LIKE A CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA.
I LIKE THE IDEA AND I'M ONLY
GOING TO SUPPORT CANDIDATES THAT
SUPPORT AMERICA FIRST, SAVE
AMERICA, MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN POLICIES BECAUSE THEY WORK
AND THEY WORK AND THEY WILL WORK
AGAIN.
ALL THE PROBLEMS JOE BIDEN HAS,
SENATOR, ARE PREVENTABLE AND
FIXABLE BUT WE NEED THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN POWER TO DO IT.
SO IS THAT SOMETHING THE SENATE
WILL ALSO GO BY?
WILL YOU SIGN A PLEDGE, IF
THERE'S TEN ITEMS YOU AGREE
WITH?
>> WELL, NEWT IS BRILLIANT AND
KEVIN HAS BEEN A GREAT LEADER
AND HE IS GOING TO BE SPEAKER,
BUT DONALD TRUMP IS THE LEADER
OF THIS PARTY.
NOT KEVIN McCARTHY, NOT
LINDSEY GRAHAM --
>> Sean: BASED ON THE AMERICA
FIRST AGENDA.
>> YEAH, I'M HOPING SOON HE WILL
LAY OUT A POSITIVE AGENDA.
HERE IS WHAT I WOULD DO AT THE
BORDER, HERE IS HOW I WOULD
SECURE THE BORDER AGAIN.
REMEMBER ME, I'M THE GUY THAT
CONTROLLED THE BORDER.
HERE IS WHAT I WOULD DO TO DEAL
WITH RUSSIA AND CHINA.
HERE IS WHAT I WOULD DO TO
REBUILD THE MILITARY.
AND HERE'S WHAT I WOULD DO TO
MAKE US ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND
LOWER INFLATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PROVEN HE
KNOWS HOW TO DO THESE THINGS.
HE NEEDS TO REMIND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE OF WHAT WE DID IN THE
PAST AND WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE
FUTURE.
AND IT IS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
THE ELECTION IS ABOUT THE FUTURE
AND IF THERE THIS IS A POLICY
DEBATE, WE WILL TAKE THERE -- IF
IT IS A PERSONALITY DEBATE, WE
MIGHT LOSE.
>> Sean: I WILL TAKE THE GUY
WITH THE MEAN TWEETS THAT WAS
ACTUALLY, THAT THE WORLD --
>> YES.
>> Sean: THE HOSTILE REGIME
LEADERS FEARED AND WHOSE
POLICIES LEAD TO PROSPERITY OVER
THE GUY THAT DOESN'T KNOW THAT
TODAY